bonjour défaire alors dites moi et j'ai
mal dormi
je me sens fatigué rentable ça vous
dirait de faire une séance de
luminothérapie
le soin par la lumière un traitement de
plus en plus utilisé par la clinique
d'yveline la patiente sous peine d'avoir
mal dormi elle se sent fatigué il a
besoin de récupérer un petit peu ce
matin du coup nous avons nous allons
choisir le programme turbosieste qui se
déroule en cinq minutes un peu plus de
cinq minutes le choix se fait parmi une
vingtaine de programmes la
luminothérapie est utile pour la gestion
du stress la dépression ou encore
l'alcoolo dépendance qui depuis le mois
de février j'ai déjà dit nantes mais je
j'avais du mal à me ferrand j'étais très
anxieuse seraient les pensées négatives
en arrêt d'alcool c'est bien mais vivre
sens il faut la prendre à lumino elle
apporte
pour moi elle m'a apporté de la détente
de lâcher prise en neuf mois de pratique
65 séances ont été effectuées à la
clinique d'yveline 85% se sont déclarés
satisfaits par cette méthode douce nous
savons que les médicaments ne peuvent
pas tout faire un patients dépressifs
qui est sous traitement antidépresseur
mais à peu près six mois pour aller bien
tandis que si on l'associé sous
traitement anti dépresseur à de la
luminothérapie au bout de trois mois
parfois même moins de trois mois le
patient s'améliorer en raison d'un
phénomène appelé trouble affectif
saisonnier la période hivernale est plus
propice aux troubles de l'humeur